what's going on everybody and welcome to
another python and pandas tutorial video
in this video we're going to be doing
is showing how to remove outliers
with pandas okay so
the removal of outliers is kind of a
sticky situation okay so if you
just have outliers that you don't like
about your data set you can't remove
those okay so
outliers are a part of a data set and
many circumstances
so you don't want to just remove
anything that is an outlier okay so
that's bad
use of data but in some cases you have
literally
bad data that has outliers that are
there because of some sort of glitch
or whatever and so if it's your data you
might want to fix that glitch that's
causing the outliers if it's not your
data then you must
fix the glitch yourself after the fact
so the question is what can we do to
remove outliers in a situation where the
removal of an outlier is actually
warranted because again
just because you don't like the fact
that that outlier is there does not mean
you can just
remove the outlier okay so i'm not
trying to condone any
uh any bad practice here my
uh idea here is just to show you guys if
you have a you know a legitimate
need to remove outliers how to do it so
if you're
not watching this video i imagine this
is kind of a common question people ask
so if you're not watching this video as
a part of the entire
series copy my import statements up here
and style if you're using style if
you're not using style just
just don't copy the from matplotlib
import style
and don't copy this as far as the
function here you don't need to copy
that we aren't going to be using that
right now
and so let's go ahead and get started so
we're going to make our own little
function here entirely
now also this is the data set here um
i gave a download of these stocks
the sediment analysis from my website so
if you want to use the exact same data
that we're using you can download that
i'll put the link to that in the
description
otherwise you can use your own data set
entirely so
let's go ahead and get started so we're
gonna make a new uh
function here and i guess we'll just
call it for now
define outlier
underscore fixing and we're gonna say
uh stock name
and we could let's say
i guess what we can do we could put the
mas in here but maybe for now we'll just
leave that blank
um we'll just have stock name in here so
now we're going to define the
data set and since we've already typed
it out here i'm just going to go ahead
and
copy and paste that same data stuff
so that's good now we're going to go
ahead and do is we're going to
also copy this part as well
so if you're not coming from the
previous tutorial i guess pause it and
type all of this out this is just
the files name the index column and then
yes we want to parse dates
this just makes sure that because this
file has a bunch of different companies
in it so
this line is here to this line is here
to only plot or only deal with a stock
specific stock that we're interested in
now the next line um
i guess the first thing we could do is
we could just go ahead and plot this
data
so we could just do ax
1 equals plt.sub
plot and we can make this a one by one
by one
and what do we want to plot well let's
just plot the close of whatever we're
plotting so we'll say df
uh close
dot plot and we'll just give this a
label
of price so what we're going to see here
is uh that we have a problem because um
let's see outlier fixing stock name uh
we're gonna do
bdc usd so my bitcoin prices i pull from
an api
and sometimes this api gives me very bad
data
and so there's really no way for me to
know that this data is bad
when i get it we don't know did the
price change this much or
is it bad data and anybody who knows
anything about bitcoin
we know that bitcoin is highly volatile
so this is really
a challenging scenario so anyway
let's go ahead and we're going to plot
this the other thing we need to do is
let's go ahead
and do um
plt.legend and we need to do plt.show
otherwise that's not going to show up
for us
and that should be it so let's go ahead
and run that
and eventually we'll we'll see that we
have kind of
poor price i'm just making sure i
commented that other thing out yeah
um so we should see that we have a lot
of bad data
in this data set whenever this plot
finally does show up
and so what we can do to get around this
is we can use standard deviation as a
method for detecting
bad plots okay so here is our chart
right so as you can see with this
we have quite a bit of what looks to be
bad data okay so we've got these massive
fluctuations like you know here and here
and
all of these are quite poor um we can
clearly see with our eyeball that you
know this
the upper bound price is right and it
looks like we've got a lot of drops here
that are bad data um we've also got some
misses here like this one
there's just no data in a couple of
spots and that's going to be
you know pretty normal that data is not
bad data it's just we're missing data
there
but as far as these massive you know
plummets down and then right back up
again
those are bad data but then we have also
good data where it plummets down for
example
um right here where it plummets from 800
to
almost about 700 within a really short
time frame that's a fast
jump or fall down and so we don't want
to
pick up that as bad we just want to pick
up these
these momentary lapses here where if we
zoom in we can see it's just like a
one bar down and it goes back up so
we're going to use standard deviation to
solve this problem for us
so how do we do that well just so
happens a standard deviation luckily for
us is actually built in
if you wanted to do standard deviation
yourself i believe actually have a
tutorial on
doing that completely on your own but
for now we'll use
built-in standard deviation with pandas
so
what we're going to do is underneath
where we define df we're also going to
define standard deviation now the
general
shorthand way to define standard
deviation is std
um so we'll call it std i suppose no
jokes
pd dot rolling underscore std
um it's even they do it too
so here we're going to take a rolling
standard deviation okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
reference kind of like you would do with
a moving average right you're
referencing
you know out of the previous few plots
what's the deviation here so
we're going to say what is the data set
that we want to use to perform this std
operation well we're going to use the df
and close since that's what we're
plotting and we can see it clearly has
problems
then uh for rolling uh standard
deviation we
can use six and then we can also say min
periods
and here we can just say like any form
of minimum periods that we want to
consider
and in our case um we can do
i would say just one really that
probably
will solve it and also maybe for
standard deviation instead of six that
might be a poor
idea because six um
might get us in trouble when we do
actually have real
drops let's do like 25 that's probably a
better idea
so we'll use 25 and then what we can do
is let's just plot
another example or apply another chart
basically
below it so instead of a a one by one
let's make it a two by one so that'll be
a chart on top and a chart on bottom
so axis one will be a two by one
and then we'll plot that put up a legend
and then we're gonna say
ax2 equals plt.subplot
this will be a two by one only this will
be chart number two so on the bottom
and then also we wanna share x ax1 so
that just shares the axis so when we
zoom in and stuff
uh we retain that the same
you know time frame basically um so now
we want to do is we've defined std so
now we can just plot up our stds so
std.plot
label and we'll just call this uh
deviation and again let's plot
we have to say plt.legend here
and plot that show that should be good
enough for us
yes so we'll plot this up and while
we're waiting i'll go ahead and talk
about what we're going to do next so
here we'll be able to actually visually
see
the standard deviation and what we're
hoping for is when
we have a faulty price the standard
deviation should jump
very significantly so with a you know
standard deviation of 25
it's probably going to put our deviation
up you know
i don't know because we're drunk we're
dropping basically 200 almost worth of
stock price
oh here's our chart um
right so we can see here um
we can see here that we have like here
the standard deviation went up to what
looks to be my mic's in the way of
reading this value 33
okay about and some of these are
probably
bad data we could zoom in probably find
out for sure
right this one's a legitimate one but
this one's actually probably a bad one
which is interesting because this one
here
is legit actually and this is the bad
one and we can see our standard
deviation is not
um not a fan but or doesn't pick it up
necessarily
but we can come over here and here's
some prices here
and we can see clearly that um
our standard deviation says you know
these legit legit legit
bad bad bad ready you know right and
it's picking up everything that is wrong
so
uh we can kind of foresee a little bit
of a problem here just because
um we might actually pick up some legit
plots
especially here where we've got that
major crash and then here there's
another crash
this looks like a bad one um but the
rest of the prices appear to be legit so
in this scenario it would pick up this
plot and
this plot and then be right back on
track to finding uh the regular ones or
the ones that were a problem
so what can we do about this well we can
zoom out and we can see that we can kind
of estimate that
anything let me move this over a little
bit
we can say anything that is
higher than a standard deviation
of at least 40 but some of these are
legit down here
um right here let's say this is like 22.
so we could start with anything with a
standard deviation higher than say 20
is bad data okay and then these ones are
just kind of
these last few ones are kind of bad but
um that's okay
um so anything with a standard deviation
let's say a higher of 20
we want to ignore or get rid of
okay so what we can do is we come back
over to our outlier
fixing scenario and if you look see like
right here where we defined
df equals you know the lower stock name
we can do the same thing
with standard deviation so how do we do
that
so what we've got is once we define
standard deviation
we know well first of all what do we
have to do we have to
give standard deviation a column here
because right now
standard deviation does not have a
column so what we could say though
instead of std equals what we can say
here instead is df
std like this so now we've assigned a
whole column to stds
and what we can do i said no jokes i'm
sorry what we can do
is we can say now um
df equals df
where df std
is less than and let's try 20 for now
that might be a little too large
but i think we can get away with 20. and
so
now i've got now i've got that so let's
go ahead and save this
and we can plot it up and let's see what
we have now
most well at least we know most of these
will be fixed
by just doing this so we should fix most
of them
but we might have a few stragglers but
we definitely there's a kind of fine
line you want to tow because
some you don't want to get rid of too
much good data but you definitely don't
want these outliers especially for
something like stock
you know back testing or something like
this where
you know the price didn't actually drop
that much uh hold on let's see what did
we do here
ah yes we took away um it's a
straight definition darn uh so here
so we did is we just saved ourselves
another line and we so we said
uh we defined a new column so there's no
longer anything called
std so copy this and replace
that there matplotlib is probably going
to get very angry with me in a moment so
you'll see some errors
uh where are they usually they pop up if
you start to plot something and then you
don't blot it anyway there they are
one more there we go okay anyways um
so you definitely don't want to have the
bad data there and you don't want to get
rid of too much of the good data
at least in my opinion you want to get
rid of all those bad datas especially
when
we're talking about a you know price
drop of about 30 percent and then a
price rise of about 50 you know 100
actually or actually it's 50 back up so
it drops down to about 400 goes back up
to 600 let's say
uh so here we can see that now we
don't include any standard deviation
that is greater than
20 right so all of them max out at 20.
that's good
um and now we can look at our price
chart here and our price chart looks
much better this is a legitimate price
chart
barring possibly this drop here i forget
i think we looked at that one already
though
right so this price drop is definitely
almost suspect as we can see
it is right on the line of that so
we could let's see is there anybody else
that's right on the line so we got
another one that's right on the line
here
and that looks like it could be a bad
one as well hold on let's zoom in
or do this one more time
this one's hard uh this one it looks to
me to be more legit like as long as it
doesn't
it gradually goes there that's one thing
but when it drops like immediately there
uh you know it's bad so this one's close
so
would you want to get rid of that plot
maybe
and that let's see that was this one
here um
but this one for example we kind of want
to get rid of this one okay so
so it's kind of challenging because
let's see that one was really close to a
20
and this one which appears to me
to be a legitimate drop in recovery
they're both
really close uh to the line so i guess i
probably i probably won't touch those
um you can decide what you want to do
with your specific data a lot of times
you won't find yourself in a scenario
um because like bitcoin is just
historically very volatile so we have a
lot of
high volatility moments and it depends
how bad your data is
um so we had a pretty large
example of you know massive drops but
bitcoin also has legitimate
massive drops so that was kind of it's
kind of a hard scenario to use but
anyway this is
just a example of how you can get rid of
outlying plots using standard deviation
so anyways that's going to conclude this
video also just
as a quick note if you want to actually
just eradicate it from your data set
what you can do is after you've done
this you could save to the csv so you
would use pandas you know save or to
underscore csv and you could resave the
data
and you could knock off the standard
deviation column before you did that
and you would fix the data set so that
way every time you went through the data
set
you wouldn't have to calculate that
standard deviation
and then calculate less than 20 and all
that so if you're going to continually
find yourself
doing this you should just knock it off
immediately
um so anyways uh that's going to
conclude this video on how to fix
outliers again don't remove outliers
just because you're not happy
that they're there just remove outliers
if it's literally bad data like it was
in this scenario
so anyways that's it if you guys have
any questions or comments feel free to
leave those
in the comment section below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time